fomo fear of missing out is the social
anxiety you feel when all your friends
get invited to timmy's birthday party
but you're stuck at home watching tv
with your creepy uncle we live in a
world where almost everybody is
psychologically dependent on social
media and that's great news if you're an
app developer because it's easy to
harness people's social anxiety to grow
your user base and make your vc backers
unbelievably rich and happy in today's
tutorial you'll learn how to manipulate
fomo from a marketing perspective
by building an invite-only app inspired
by clubhouse from a technical
perspective
marketers have been using fomo for
thousands of years but the modern term
was coined in 1996 by dr dan herman
it's used shamelessly as a marketing
technique all over the tech world
buy bitcoin get on tick tock get a
google plus invite and most recently
get on clubhouse clubhouse as the name
implies is an invite-only app
where you can listen to people talk
about stuff like elon musk creating more
fomo for bitcoin for example
as an end user it's kind of like being
in an office building where you get to
go to a bunch of meetings all day
sounds like fun but you can only get in
the clubhouse if someone invites you
with your phone number
but once you're in you then get two
invites to send to your best friends
then they invite two of their best
friends and the cycle continues until
you have a massive fomo pyramid
it's not a pyramid scheme it is a it's
not even a scheme per se
it's and that's a much more cost
effective way to get users than spending
most of your series a
on facebook ads the whole thing is a
marketer's dream really you have all the
cool kids talking about it on social
media and if you happen to be a loser
without an invite you'll need to go beg
for one from your best friend
but when your best friend says they gave
out their invites to their better best
friends
you'll just have to pretend like you
don't care and that's what we call 100
organic locally sourced fear of missing
out fomo can literally get people to do
anything
like invest in assets that are worth
almost nothing buy stupid products that
nobody needs
and even download apps that aren't all
that good and now that you know how
powerful it is
let's have some fun and take a look at
how to implement fomo from a technical
perspective
now before we get into the code i want
to point out that we'll be going through
things pretty quickly
but you can reference the full source
code on github and also the article on
fireship io
we'll be using react and firebase for
the refi stack for this demo
but you can apply the same logic to
virtually any tech stack
if we open up the demo you'll notice a
sign in page where the user is first
required to enter their phone number
if that phone number is not on the
invite list in our database
then they can't sign in the invite list
is just a database collection in
firestore where each document id in the
database
is the phone number that's been invited
then it contains a field of sender that
has the user id of whoever sent the
invite
but if the number is on the invite list
then the user can sign in
when the button is clicked it will send
a text message to that phone number
then have the user verify the code in
this form at which point the user is
signed in to the application
and once authenticated they can then
invite the phone numbers of their best
friends
this will create a new invite in the
database which will then trigger a cloud
function
to send that user a text message
inviting them to use the app
now one important thing to point out
here is that firebase will automatically
send the first text message for the user
to verify
the sign in the second message though
that goes to the invited user
will need to be sent programmatically
which is not something that firebase can
do
but there are many programmatic sms apis
out there with the most famous option
being twilio
i'm not a huge fan of twilio myself but
luckily there are a lot of good
alternatives out there
i've heard good things about message
bird and the api we'll be using in this
video
is plivo it has a really nice ui and
will give you a free phone number
and credit to get started in the sandbox
now let's go ahead and jump into the
source code
to build this app i started with a
generic react application
using the create react app tool inside
the project i've installed two
dependencies
firebase and react firebase hooks the
entire front-end source code is
contained
inside the app.js file if we go in there
we'll import our firebase dependencies
which include firebase auth and
firestore
along with a few built-in hooks from
react and then the use off state hook
from react firebase hooks
which allows us to listen to the state
of the current user
whether they're logged in or logged out
and lastly we have use collection data
which allows us to make a query to a
collection in the firestore database
and update the ui in real time whenever
the data in that collection changes
from there we'll need to connect our
firebase project to the react app
we can do that by creating a web app
from the firebase console which will
give us a set of project credentials to
copy
and while we're in the firebase console
let's go over to the authentication tab
and make sure to enable phone
authentication now we can go back to our
code
and initialize the firebase app the two
sdks that we'll be using
are firebase auth and firestore so let's
go ahead and reference those
as global variables in the root app
component we're going to listen to the
user's authentication state
if we do have a user which means they're
logged in then we'll go ahead and render
the send invites component
which takes the current user as a prop
otherwise we'll show the sign up
component the initial user state will be
signed out
so let's go ahead and focus on the sign
up component now in order to implement
phone authentication
the user will need to verify a captcha
normally this means the user has to go
through the annoying
process of verifying that they're not a
spam bot however
the modern user-friendly way to do this
is with an invisible recaptcha
which will attempt to verify the user in
the background and only ask them
questions when it's absolutely necessary
to implement an invisible recaptcha
we'll first set it up as state on the
component
using the use state hook and then we're
going to reference a native dom
element with the use ref hook you need
to have an empty div
somewhere in the ui to attach the
recaptcha to from there we'll
implement a callback and the use effect
hook if the recaptcha has not been
defined yet
then we'll go ahead and define it by
creating a new instance
of a firebase auth recaptcha verifier it
takes the empty div as its first
argument
then options as the second argument
we'll just want to make sure that it has
a size
of invisible from there we can verify it
by calling the verify method
which returns a promise and then once
verified we'll go ahead
and set the recaptcha instance on the
component state
and now that we have that state we can
go into the jsx and
render a phone number verification
component that passes the recaptcha down
as a prop that allows us to only show
the login form
after the recaptcha has been verified
now let's implement the phone number
verification component
its purpose is to collect the user's
phone number digits from a form
then make a read request to firestore to
validate that that number has been
invited
if the number has been invited then
we'll set that value to true
and then the user can log in and
firebase will return a confirmation
result
which is just a confirmation that they
sent a text message to that user
the user will then need to verify that
code in a second form
and once that's verified we can consider
them fully authenticated
now one final thing i'm doing here is
formatting the number with a plus one in
front of it
when working with any programmatic phone
api they almost always want the phone
number
in echo164 format it's just a plus sign
with the country code
followed by the main phone number digits
now in the jsx we're going to create a
controlled form
input with react by setting the value to
the digit state
then we'll update the state with the
current value by listening to the on
change event
and setting the digits to the value in
the form when they change
from there we can implement the use
effect hook and give it the phone number
as a dependency
if the phone number length equals 12
then we know we have a full length phone
number
at which point we can make a read
request to the database to see if that
phone number exists
in the invites collection ref get will
read the document
and if it exists then we'll go ahead and
set the invited state
to exist which will either be true or
false from there we can go back to the
html
and we'll add a button that is hidden if
the user is not invited
but if they are invited then we'll fire
the sign in with phone number method
when the button is clicked
we'll make it an async function so we
can await the auth
sign in with phone number method which
takes the phone number and the recaptcha
as
arguments the return value is the
confirmation result
which again is a confirmation from
firebase that they sent a text message
to that user
the final step in this component is to
then show another form
when that confirmation result is present
it's also a controlled input
on the code state on the component then
below that we have a button
that will fire the verify code function
when it's clicked the verify code
function
is also an async function that will
confirm the code on the confirmation
result
and that's how we get an invited user
logged into the app but now that they're
logged in
we need to give them a way to send
invites to their friends
the frontend implementation happens here
in the send invites component first we
have a database query
that grabs all of the invites that that
user has sent if the query length is
less than two
then we allow that user to create a new
invite in the database with somebody
else's phone number
that's easy enough but the tricky part
is how do we now send a text message to
that user
that's a job that needs to happen from a
backend server which we can implement in
firebase using cloud functions
by running the firebase inet functions
command i can quickly add a back end to
this react app
let's go into the functions directory
and open the index.js file
now what we want our backend to do is
run a cloud function
whenever a new firestore document is
created
in the invites collection that's really
easy to achieve
by simply exporting a function that
points to that path in the database
then we use oncreate to run some backend
code whenever a new document is created
there
to send a text message we need three
pieces of information
we need the from phone number which is
our phone number the two number which is
the one the user has invited to the app
and then the actual message that we want
to send to that phone number
now in order to send the text we need to
use a third party service like twilio or
in this case plibo
plivo has an sdk for node so we can
install that in the functions directory
with npm
we can then import it and then
initialize the client
with our id and token which you'll find
on the dashboard when you sign up for
this service
and finally we send the text message by
calling client
messages create that returns a promise
so we'll make it the return value from
the function
because a cloud function expects a
promise as its return value
you can deploy your backend to the cloud
by running firebase deploy only
functions
and now if you go to the ui and create a
new invite it should send a text message
to that user
congratulations you no longer have fomo
but jomo because you can just build your
own fomo driven app from scratch
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there but i do want to point out that
the code we've implemented
is not fully secure yet because we
haven't implemented firestore rules yet
if you want to learn how to build fully
secure features with react and firebase
consider becoming a pro member at
buyership io
and taking my full course on that topic
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one